mais d'abord plus fou que jamais charles
trenet sa poésie communicative sur la
scène du palais des congrès c'était hier
soir la première de son nouveau
spectacle tous les fans de cet éternel
jeune homme de 80 ans était là aznavour
moustaki en passant aussi par le
cinéaste georges lautner par exemple et
puis pour nous marie claire gauthier et
denis pagès faut leur demander à eux moi
je n'en vois pas beaucoup hélas tout
tout ce que j'aimais sont morts mais
enfin je suis certain qu'il ya quand
même une génération de gens venus
n'écrivent pas ils sont très réservés en
ce moment les poètes
deux poètes il en reste au moins 4000
personnes ont applaudi hier soir il y
avait des témoins
la mer le long mais c'est simple la mer
qu'on va danser le long des golfes
clairs
ben pourquoi j'en prépare aux orbes et
non je ferai jamais du championnat
on va danser
blondin
la mère nous a montré qu'on peut faire
autre chose que de la chanson qui ne
voulait pas dire grand chose et que
s'appliquait était une bonne chose
en
mon camion
le geste a dit j'ai tout l'album
mais j'ai pas une super chaîne
là j'ai pas chanter une bonne trentaine
de chansons j'ai chanté 30 chansons
bonne enfant
londres
elle est si fière score déçu